Hello, there.
I am Chukwuemeka Afigbo from
the Developer Relations team
at Google.
As you may already
know, Google has
a ton of developer
content available online
that enables developers
all over the world
to create awesome
apps and solutions
on a variety of platforms.
This content includes
developer documentation,
software development
kits, and lots
of videos for
developers like you.
Unfortunately, due to
internet challenges
in many parts of the
world, a lot of developers
are not able to
take full advantage
of this awesome content.
An example of this is when
you want to run a codelab
and need to download
and install the SDK
over a slow or nonexistent
internet connection.
Another example is when
it takes 30 minutes
to watch that 10 minute tutorial
video on your favorite API
or platform due to
constant buffering caused
by a flaky connection.
This is why we have
created a DVD series
with the latest and greatest
content on it-- such as videos,
documentation, and
SDKs for developers
in internet-challenged regions.
Now you will have
offline access to many
of the Google SDKs, developer
videos, and documentation
when you need them.
If you're interested in
getting your hands on one
of these DVDs or USB
drives, get in touch
with a Google Developer
group near you.
I am Chukwuemeka Afigbo,
wishing you all the best
from the Google campus
in Mountain View.